hi in this module i'm going to be
talking about machine learning and give
you an overview of all the topics we'll
cover
so remember that machine learning in the
process of taking data and converting it
into models and with those models you
can go and perform inferences and answer
all sorts of questions
so we're going to focus on reflex based
models these are models including linear
classifiers neural networks which in
which inference is very fast and feed
forward which makes them very attractive
so in a nutshell this is what a reflex
space model is we'll call a reflex space
model a predictor and the predictor
takes as input sum x and produces some
output
y
and in general x can be something
arbitrary like an image or a text
and
y is going to be restricted and that
particular restriction is going to
determine what type of prediction task
we are talking about
we'll consider two common cases of
prediction tasks here
the first is binary classification so in
binary classification the predictor is
also called a classifier
and the output y is called a label and
that label can either be plus one for
the positive class or minus one for the
negative class
so some examples of binary
classification problems there's fraud
detection where x is a credit card
transaction and we're trying to predict
why whether there's fraud or no fraud so
that the transaction can be blocked or
not
another example is moderating online
discussion forums so the input x is an
online comment a piece of text and
you're trying to predict why whether
it's toxic or not so that the comment
can be flagged or taken down
appropriately
and finally here's an example from
physics
so after the higgs boson was discovered
scientists want to know how does it
decay
so the hadron collider collected a bunch
of data which includes
measurements of events so here x is a
measurement of particular event you're
trying to predict
whether it was a decay event or simply
background
so the second type of task we're going
to consider is regression so in
regression
y is going to be a real number
and it's generally known as the response
so here are some examples of regression
problems so in poverty mapping acts as a
satellite image and you're trying to
predict why which is the asset wealth
index of the homes in that area in the
satellite image
in housing you might want to predict
using the information about the house
location number of bedrooms year and
predict the price
and finally
you might be interested in predicting
arrival times given where you're going
why there are conditions at the time
what time of day it is and you're trying
to predict why which is a time of
arrival
so the main difference between
regression and classification is that in
classification y is a discrete
entity and in regression it is a
continuous entity
so the final thing we're going to talk
about is structured prediction so
instruction prediction is a little bit
of a catch-all an instruction prediction
y is simply a complex object
so some examples include machine
translation where x the input is a
sentence in one language and y is its
translation in another language
dialog can also be cast as structure
prediction you're given a conversational
history between a user and agent for
example in a virtual assistant setting
and you're trying to predict why which
is the next utterance that the agent
should say
another example is image captioning
which might be useful for visual
assistive technologies
acts is an image of a scene and why is a
sentence describing or narrating that
scene
image segmentation which is useful for
autonomous driving
takes an image of a scene as x and
produces y which is a segmentation of
that scene into a region's corresponding
objects in the real world
so it might seem daunting at first to be
able to generate segmentations or
sentences or
texts
but there's a secret here which is that
many structure prediction problems can
be actually decomposed into a sequence
of multi-class
classification problems
and this allows us to leverage the
machinery that we'll talk about in just
multi-class classification
or structure prediction
so here is the roadmap of
the rest of the modules in the machine
learning unit
so first we're going to start with
regression and classification the bread
and butter of machine learning we're
going to focus on the most simple
settings linear models
where we're training using radiant
descent
then we're going to step over to
algorithms and introduce stochastic
gradient descent which is going to give
us major speed ups over gradient descent
next we're going to hop over to models
and improve
from linear models so first we'll show
that actually even linear models can be
pushed to its limits by using non-linear
features using the linear machinery we
can use feature templates to organize
the set of features that we have
then we'll talk about neural networks
which also allows you to have nonlinear
predictors but allow these
nonlinearities to be learned from data
following neural networks we're going to
look at the back propagation algorithm
for computing gradients automatically so
you don't have to do it yourself
manually
so you can train neural networks
we're going to hop back over here and
talk about differential programming
which is a generalization or extension
of neural networks that will enable us
to build all sorts of complicated deep
learning models
using
like building blocks
and all this is generally done in the
context of supervised learning we're
going to touch on unsupervised learning
a little bit and introduce the classical
k-means algorithm for clustering points
and finally we're going to end on a few
nodes so first is generalization the
question of if you train a machine
learning model on a particular set of
data
when does it
is it able to generalize to a new set of
examples
and finally i'm going to talk about best
practices like cross-validation and how
do you do machine learning in practice
so that concludes this module
you